sempé moi je maintiens ce que j'ai dit
mais la monte elle dit mais ne s'est pas
un vote d'exaspération c'est un vote
d'adhésion mais d'adhésion à quoi
d'adhésion à des gens qu'on proposait le
même programme en bretagne où le même
programme en bourgogne franche comté
moi je cherche toujours la façade
maritime de la bourgogne franche comté
quand elle nous dit mais sauvadet du
fait c'est la même chose
excusez moi les compétences attendait
les compétences de la région c'est pas
les compétences du département
donc c'est pas c'est pas du tout un vote
d'adhésion à des propositions qui
n'aimait l'expansion de la tête les
hommes et la région vous allez vous y
avez vous avez vous avez bénéficié d'un
vote d'exaspération cet objectif c'est
cet objectif ces deux autres fait c'est
l'ump s non mais c'est un changement
mais je sais je sais je sais maman tels
que vous adorez les slogans et que vous
ne savez pas faire autre chose que des
slogans vos slogans au marché pour le
premier tour très bien moi j'en prends
acte je ne conteste pas votre victoire
de premier tour mais me dis simplement
ce sera très bien pour le deuxième je
vous dis simplement oui pour un deuxième
tour je pense que les électeurs
regarderont aussi d'un petit peu plus
près parce que vous proposez pour la
région
la région s'est pas de problème de
l'union européenne s'est pas de problème
j'ai département sept problèmes de la
région
c'est le problème de la région ne soit
que si oncle et slogan c'est les slogans
c'est très confortable mais contrôler
les choses